today we're celebrating a drew getter
right here
um and she's from watts south los
angeles and has spent the last 50 years
educating children
from underserved communities take a look
at her story
hi i'm dolores sheen aka
antalores and i'm the executive director
and co-founder of the xinwei school and
culture center in watts south la the
school opened in 1971
50 years ago and we're still here
reaching out a teacher
i was going to be a doctor i dropped out
of school took montessori courses so i
could be an educator our curriculum is
enriched
and we use everything we can in our
power to develop and encourage critical
thinking sign language drama music we
have a cricket club
the first cricket club in the hood i
teach harp
violin cello bass piano we had all these
pumpkins in our little garden and that's
how the shenway bakery was born
the child wagon was launched on
juneteenth of this year to allow the
children to serve the community come get
your delicious pumpkin bread
i'm never gonna retire because as long
as i can give i think i'll live it's a
good feeling when you know that
someone's gonna walk out
knowing more than they did when they
came in and you had a part of it
i think that's why i love children so
much
sorry
it's like
good in the hood
welcome live and in person dolores sheen
aka aunt dolores
thank you and i understand you brought
two special gentlemen here today yeah
some good cooks
this is
this is marcus and that's jordan
marcus i'd like to ask what your
favorite thing is about being a part of
this community
it's fun
i love that you summed up one word that
speaks volumes
and jordan what about for you i like the
food
i think something all
people can relate to and appreciate and
you also have sheen way sister school in
ghana africa will you please tell us
about that program
our school here is in the underserved
area of what they call south la in the
hood our school in ghana is in the bush
it's like an underserved area we were
the first registered private school in
the bolton region
um
and you guys brought some baked goods
for us and um these are treats from the
sheen way bakery right yes the students
own and operate their bakery because
it's a history of why we have the bakery
and the history stems from when the
community and richard pryor helped us
get a peace treaty with the bloods and
the cryptids to the main gang factions
and we wanted to say thank you and that
year we had a lot of pumpkins in our
garden so i said let's try to make some
pumpkin bread and they said let's give
richard pryor some so he loved the
pumpkin bread
and that's how the victory got started
and not only that he came back three
times to talk with the dialogue and that
set a different perspective on the
community like someone knows we're here
someone knows our pain
that was more than any money or anything
anybody could give and to this day he is
our hero
the
layers of importance and beauty just
keep unfolding and we also have some
special people joining us right here in
the audience who are proud of you and
what you have done for your community
please welcome principal roy sadakane
faculty and alumni from machine way
school hello
[Applause]
i love that principle roy what is your
hope for sheen way in the next 50 years
currently as antolorus had mentioned
where we have a school in sasakopa ghana
and we're starting a new digital
infrastructure that will connect los
angeles our los angeles school to the
school in south super ghana well you're
gonna need support
and you deserve that and to commemorate
your 50th anniversary our friends at
conagra brands foundation are donating
twenty thousand dollars
school
and educational center in watts
california
all right
thank you
thank you dolores
thank you marcus and jordan principal
roy and everyone at the sheen wade
school and cultural center in watts for
more information you can go on our
website at thedrewberrymartial.com to
support this incredible institution
[Music]